everyone out of the street now go that
way this way out of the street all y'all
looking at me doesn't actually matter
like a vision boy I see with clarity
cluster like my name is Gary Vee table
up I've been telling you
countless buddy I'm Triple A giving a
pedigree Devine and a special my
specialty I'm putting the works on I'm
Jerry the moving furniture heaven
[Music]
it's gonna be interesting he's really
he's really getting into basketball you
know that
mom you had to see what happened
yesterday you know it was tough for me
because I wasn't in control you know
because I couldn't talk the whole time
because the founders had a talk you know
no I'm not gonna watch this too bro I'm
flying home and I'm gonna go home and
hang out with the kids look love you mom
yeah how are you really good the the
last scene of this show went really well
for me like really well and I'm not
[ __ ] kidding with you that's
literally what it was so then so that
that was in my mind and and the and the
way the day went was in my mind and like
making the like the like the green room
lab not the green one the control room
like one of the got young kids who's a
fan came to me it's like she's like it's
so crazy the control room is like dead
quiet the whole day every time you're on
there's a buzz and then four times
everybody's laughing their ass off right
so all this is happening so bring this
nice chat I'm like you know what's these
I talk about like what's gonna happen
next when you know this that I'm like I
mean the real punchline here is that
like this town is actually now gonna
know that I'm a real star and I'm gonna
go in like I'm gonna go make some real
magic happen and it was yeah I thought I
knew that you I know you guys have known
each other a long time so I thought
you'd like that it was something in that
moment that made me text you the reason
I'm really calling you is but I'm
telling you man like I think we're gonna
have a Norman like I genuinely believe I
believe the [ __ ] that I've been
pumping you guys for a decade I feel
like it's all crescendo to the moment
like I really think I've got it I just
think it's really smart for Pete me to
put the most valuable asset I have in my
life which is my time in your hands four
five meetings between today and because
I think the multiplier of the
exponential maybe ass the executive
maybe it's maybe it's
a setup like this guy's gonna run the
world like I'm telling you maybe it's I
don't
maybe it's the CEO I don't know but I
and I and the cool part is I'm not
looking I'm looking to be strategic I
just know I'll blow them away over a
drink in an hour
and good [ __ ] will happen for us
what do you mean what am I trying to do
I'm trying to do what I always do
I'm hacking people don't get it the [ __ ]
doesn't happen by accident
it happens because of that I'm [ __ ]
strategic as [ __ ] people just think I'm
like go do it and funny and a nice guy
[ __ ] Savage that's what I my my biz
dev skills are [ __ ] the best
I just don't show it there's not moments
to show it you got the beep out 98% if
you decide to use this are we
reminiscing about some of the greatest
Hallett of all time hello are you
Christine Gary thank you so brother
[Music]
sorry about that handcuff go ahead super
fun we're what I was about to say to
Chris is like we're where we have a new
website coming up for Vayner that's
gonna be very focused on just examples
of our work and video as I continue to
push this Facebook video commercial
thing but I do think that if these club
run on this five-second bumpers on a
Super Bowl
I'd like that featured as well so super
exciting just a lot of fun I had an
incredible incredible meeting with the
new with last week Tyler knows that I'm
trying to see him every 30 days every 45
days and so I just I'm really excited I
think it's gonna be a great year and I
just appreciate all you guys hustle and
I can't wait to see you guys and and let
keep me update on what's going on here
[Music]
and that'd be pretty but she took nice
you might get bothered
top user pills the world on your
shoulders can show that we work better
when you suffer but I don't take joy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
though
[Music]
I'm hurting your first
you want to see me and can say it Howard
my name is Chuck
[Music]
cries oh God
like two minutes
[Music]
Alex a specialist in New York
[Music]
bro-bro yes ro ro like a biggest [ __ ]
Sandro
[Music]
[Music]
you can be seen
and the bottom box me max you know you
can't throw every single cut you want
you have their patients up there
sixteen years to play
and that's
everyone out of the street now go that
way all y'all look at me
[Music]
[Music]
there we go
that's a great picture
guys these lovely men he is took to
those who thank you thanks for coming
out
I am the voice in your head since you
was a boy from school and that [ __ ]
pretty but she took nice you might get
bored
abusive pills the world on your
shoulders can show that we work better
when you suffer but I don't take joy
enough sandé was there for you I was no
one